good morning John it's April 20th it's
4/20 which I guess can only mean one
thing I blaze it look I don't smoke pot
I have I don't really like it and I'm
not gonna sit here and tell you that
cannabis is not harmful in any way and
then it's gonna cure every disease or
whatever but I think it's ridiculous and
unjustifiable that marijuana is
criminalized while more addictive and
dangerous substances like alcohol and
tobacco are available at every gas
station in the country so here are seven
reasons why marijuana should be
decriminalized and three reasons why
it's more complicated than some people
might make it out to be one legalizing
marijuana is good for local economies it
increases tax revenue and it can
increase the amount of small businesses
that are successful and I think that we
should regulate both growers and sellers
to make sure that those businesses
aren't just giant conglomerates we
should not let like a bunch of Richie
Rich pants who spent decades sending
people to prison for selling marijuana
suddenly get even richer selling it to
illicit marijuana is a source of income
for drug cartels that we could just take
away instantaneously free THC CBD other
compounds in marijuana are legitimate
medication they can help with autoimmune
diseases people with chronic pain
seizure disorders vomiting in cancer
patients and yet US law defines
marijuana as having no medical use this
is scientifically inaccurate or because
it can sometimes help with chronic pain
it can help people who are dependent on
opiate and that seems like a good thing
to not put in the same category as
heroin 5 the most successful story may
be in human history of decreasing the
use of an addictive substance is the
story of cigarettes you can decrease use
without criminalization 6 the
criminalization of marijuana creates
real and obvious harm arrests including
juvenile arrests have long term impacts
on people's lives convictions even more
so and felony convictions result in
lifelong marginalization and
disenfranchisement and this is why when
young white people get found out for
selling marijuana they often don't get
arrested because everyone realizes that
ruining someone's life for selling pot
is dumb and what we see over and over
again is similar rates of drug use among
white and black people but far more
black people getting arrested for it and
finally number 7 I don't hear people
talking about this one much when we make
something very illegal that is less
dangerous than something that is
perfectly League
I think that weakens the authority of
the rule of law people start to ask like
if you're gonna ruin my life for doing
something that doesn't seem like a big
deal to me then maybe the legal system
isn't out to protect me maybe it is in
fact out to harm me that's a big deal
the more people who feel that way about
the law the worse
society in total is now let's do the
part where we admit that this isn't as
simple as a lot of people like to make
it out to be first reason why driving
while stoned is dangerous and has been
proven to be so if there is no weed
breathalyzer so this is a problem it is
also not a new problem it's a problem we
currently have - in legalizing weed I
think some people will think that that's
like basically the government saying
weed isn't bad for you but it is long
term use of marijuana especially by
young people has been shown to have all
kinds of negative effects most worrying
ones being that it can increase the
symptoms of depression and other mental
health problems in cannabis use is a
risk factor for schizophrenia a more
information check out this very good
healthcare triage video and finally
number three you can't just legalize it
those are two nice little words but it's
complicated I don't we do with people
who are currently in prison who can sell
it how much how is it tagged what
commercial zones are dispensaries
allowed to be in like these things have
to be figured out but the status quo is
a law that harms more than the drug and
I think that we're finally waking up to
that John I'll see you on Tuesday
hey I hope that the comments aren't a
disaster and here are some videos that
you can go watch if you would like to
learn more on this topic